I think the whole question that Anita was
asking is about chance and how we can assure
that girls like Anita and many, many, many
other girls in developing countries would
have the chance. More access to education
and making their lives better and therefore
the whole economy better as well as reducing
poverty. Providing that chance means partly
breaking down cultural values and traditions
about the fact that girls are measured in
terms of their success in life by getting
married and having children. Girls need to
have access to education. They need to be
able to continue their education. And for
this affirmative policies may be necessary,
governments, as well as other ways to assure
that girls are not taken out of school because
of poverty or for other reasons. And Especially
during this crisis , where poverty rates can
go up, incomes will come down. There is a
real danger of girls being taken out of school
before boys will be taken out of school. In
designing policies as a policy maker, in designing
policies and managing the crisis I think we
have to really make sure that we explicitly
include this aspect to make sure that girls
continue to be in school. For instance you
can build in cash transfer programs to be
given with the condition that the recipient
continues to have girls and boys stay in school.
In the more medium term, I think how to change
cultural values and traditions become s a
much more longer term issue, but having role
models, having girls understand that their
self esteem should not just be measured by
that fact that they're married and having
children needs to be changed. And I think
democracy in the case of Indonesia has played
an important role. Where you find all the
way from a president being a woman, to ministers,
to governors, to village heads being women.
And making decisions that are in favor of
women as well as becoming role models become
a very important part of the change. And finally
I think the legal part, making sure that girls
and women understand their rights so that
if they succeed in business they have the
property rights and they don't lose it just
because everything is under their husband's
name. So it was a good session. And I would
hope that a big message coming out of the
world economic from Davos is that all the
crisis messages about trade and finance, in
managing this crisis we must have a very proactive
and specific policy to ensure that girls like
Anita will continue to have the chance. Thank
you.